You have aproximately a 171 billion total brain cells
86 billion of these are neurons
that process information, sense varied stimuli
and make you...
Well, you
But are there things in every day life
that reduce this count?
What will kill your brain cells?
We used to think that the brain couldn't
produce new neurons
Although neurons are stabled cell type, meaning they don't multiple themselves
We now know that new neurons are produced from neural stem cells
Throughout our life time
But this happens only in certain areas of our brain
Mainly in two small regions in the forebrain
So, while we can make new neurons
Brain cell death in large amounts may be dangerous and irreversible
For example, within 5 minutes of a good blow to the head
Axons are compressed and calcium rushes into your neurons
Which can signal a number of different pathways and enzymes to begin cell death
This may explain the confussion, lost of consciousness
and sensitivity to sound or light common in a consussion
Getting enough zs?
Although the brain can react against short term sleep deprivation
A 2014 study showed too many all-nighters
may be killing neurons in the locus coeruleus
This a region of the brain responsible for coordinating
motivation, and maintaining attention and arousal
And after extended wake periods
we become unable to make important proteins to keep these neurons alive
But don't stress about that, literally
Long term stress has been associated with
damage to our hippocampus
And a reduced ability to make new neurons
which may explain why extreme stress can lead to numerous mental illnesses
Like depression, anxiety, PTSD and schizophrenia
Nicotine affects the hippocampus as well
Cutting the creation of new neurons by 50%
While also increasing cell death
Like the smell of gasoline or permanent markers?
Although they don't cause brain damage directly
Some of the chemicals in them are as asphyxiants
meaning it will despise oxygen from the air you breath
And deprive your tissues of oxygen!
Ultimately killing brain cells
Carbon dioxide, commonly released from stoves, furnaces,
grills and cars, works the same way
By hijacking your hemoglobin
which normally carries oxygen in your blood
Cells in major organs, like the brain and heart
will soffocate and die heightened of levels
But what about alcohol?
It appears that short term exposure to alcohol
doesn't kill brain cells!
But... It can reduce communication between them
And over a longer period, chronic alcohol consumption
can activate immune cells in the brain to produce pro inflammatory chemicals
and free radicals that can lead to cell death
Alcoholics can also develop a B-vitamin thiamine deficiency called Wernicke-Korsakoff syndrome
which can kill off brain cells and lead to memory problems,
amnesia and lack of muscle coordination
Taking a break from drinking may be the best way to
promote neural stem cell growth and other factors from neurogenesis
But no matter how much we might fear losing brain cells
We might have no choice in the matter
Our brain declines by 5% of its volume per weight per decade after the age of 40
With the rate increasing around the age of 70
Most widely experienced is memory loss
which can be a normal part of aging
Overall, we shouln't be kept a night wondering how many brain cells we lost today
as losing them may be a sign that things are alright
During development we produce many more neurons than we need
and brain cells have to die to maintain the brain's complex organization
Research in rats suggest that we lose neurons in our prefontal cortex
as a way of reorganizing our brain during and after puberty
More neurons doesn't necessarily make for a better or a smarter person
And sometimes cell death makes for a healthy life
Thank you so much to Science Sam for narrating this video
You need to follow her on instagram @science.sam
She'll make you really inspired by science and also even more interested in your brain
Know what doesn't kill your brain cells?
Podcasts!
So you should to ours
We've just released our first ever live podcast from Just For Laughs
We were super nervous, I think we pulled it off
Let us know what do you think using the hashtag #SidenotePodcast
And we'll you next week for a new science video
Peace